hi drew thanks for having me again
i was gonna say welcome back to the show
yeah i know it's always a pleasure well
it is always a pleasure because you're
so beautiful and so talented
but my gosh are you effective
too and it's just so
inspiring let's talk beauty you say that
putting on makeup
is one of the most selfish times we have
i was inspired by that will you
elaborate
yes i mean that when you're putting on
makeup right you have to use two hands
and the best part of it
you were staring at yourself in the
mirror right and what are you saying to
yourself right
so for me my beauty application time is
where i reassure myself i tell myself oh
you're beautiful look at the highlighter
poppy look at those cheekbones girl you
can slay right so
so it's the most selfish time that you
have and one that you should god and use
used very well
i'm so inspired and i'm going to be
carrying that with me as a mom you know
we don't take time for ourselves and
there is an incredible
mom of five who needed a little beauty
help with her routine
and i want to show what happened sharon
take a look at this
you know hi my name is kim i'm from
minita virginia and i
am mother to five fantastic children
between the ages of
4 and 17. as a mom i am
100 confident but at the end of the day
kim and her confidence in herself is
probably somewhere
between a zero and a five percent
i know i'm a part of my children's life
i'm there i see the events
but you won't see me in a picture
because i don't feel like
i deserve to be in that picture maybe
that's what it is i cried the other
night when i looked at my pictures and
realized i'm not in them
that's pretty much where my confidence
level is and but i'm
hoping to fix that one day my experience
with makeup
is very minimal any type of tips any
type
of techniques tricks that i can use
because when you are relying on a 13
year old
for makeup tips it's a sad situation
all right how are you doing kimberly so
great to meet you
oh it's wonderful to meet you thank you
yes
what i'm gonna do with you today is show
you how
we can take that to the next level so
we're gonna start with complexion
let's get your sponge working it's one
of the biggest mistakes people make when
they use sponges they use it dry
um they're meant to be used wet you
always need to wet them
and make them moist because it really
helps it absorb better on your skin and
place
the product without it just sucking the
product into the sponge
so now let's go with the contour step
you're gonna go straight to your cheeks
and you're gonna just apply that gently
perfection
now let's get into brows you just wanna
go in there and brush your brow hairs
so you want to tame that and you want to
shape that
and then last but not least we're going
to give you a red lip because you know
date night now that's beautiful
i am riveted by the way kim is here
to show us how you look now
he looks incredible
thank you okay kim how do you feel
what is the inner dialogue now i just
feel beautiful
i mean outside inside i just feel like
everything is right with the world right
now sharon
i know that there's something that you
wanted to say to kim and i would love to
listen
look you are you have to be your own
cheerleader and like i said to you last
time
when those voices come in and try to
make you feel not beautiful
you tell them voices you are the
prettiest woman in the world and you
lift your head up high and you walk
around they're confident because you
are gorgeous
yes look you are in my bathroom every
morning
kim um we wanted to leave with something
uh
have a little something to keep that
confidence going and
our friends at nordstrom want to give
you a five thousand dollar gift card
um and
they also had this really cool idea of
doing some virtual styling sessions
with the clothes um i like that they
wanted to add that detail in as well
thank you nordstroms
thank you so much i'm so oh my gosh i'm
so excited and nervous and everything
all at once
thank you kim you are so beautiful
on the outside and the inside where it
counts the most
thank you so much thank you
now sharon you have just affected change
in ways that i have not seen possible
and you have a special announcement for
us today
another milestone let's tell me tell
everyone about it please
yes i am so excited to announce our new
campaign we pull up for change the
launch is today it's called make you
black
now most people don't know but if you go
to the dictionaries you'll be really
surprised by the definition of black
the related words the synonyms of black
you have things like wicked evil
vile wrong in human threat and
oppressive really
and so language is really important for
us to tackle if we're going to dismantle
systemic racism
and you know let's show the world
together how
beautiful black truly is and that's what
make it black is all about and we've
partnered with
nine incredible brands including your
brand which i'm so excited
came on board this program with flower
beauty we have morphe colourpop we have
alter and so many incredible brands that
have come together
um to take a stand on this campaign and
100
of the net proceeds of this um the sale
of these products is going to go into
the pull up for change
small business impact fund which is a
fund that we've just set up to help
black founders
i really want to thank also um the
people i work with who i
founded flower beauty with um the mesa
team because they here was our original
packaging
and thanks to sharon and mesa
stepping up to the plate which i really
appreciate we have now
made it black in honor of you and all
these other companies
morphy color pop nyx
i mean sharon beautiful thank you
for making me a better person making
flower beauty a better company
make it black campaign launches today
so go on our website to check it out
buy from the companies who are meeting
the moment and thank you sharon
you